see this headline from my friends at the
blaze
pat benatar says she won't perform hit
me with your best shot song out of
deference to the victims of mass
shootings
i said what i mean you know i my
instinct immediately was to laugh
hysterically not at the idea of mass
shootings mass shootings are a horrific
tragedy we don't want to laugh at that
people lose loved ones it's despicable
it's horrible it's a horrific tragedy
but
she's going to stop singing that song
and she somehow thinks that's going to
make a difference what a what a what a
massively inflated sense of
self-importance and also a twisted sense
about what her own song's about anyway
this is this is what it says
benatar made the admission in an
interview with usa today while
discussing why she chooses to cover
other songs during her latest tour and
we're not doing hit me with your best
shot and fans are having a heart attack
and i'm like i'm sorry in deference to
the victims of the families of these
mass shootings i'm not singing it it
goes on i tell them if you want to hear
the song go home and listen to it
she then goes on to say the title is
tongue-in-cheek but you have to draw the
line if the title is tongue-in-cheek
what are you even talking about
what do you think that when people are
at the bar
dancing a couple of drinks in or maybe
not a couple of drinks whatever they're
feeling good and they're hit me with you
think they're thinking oh pat benatar
she is fan in the flames of mass
shootings around the united states no
this is a celebrity with a twisted mind
hate to say it and an inflated sense of
self-importance these celebrities really
crack me up
not always the sharpest tax in the
drawer now if you really are concerned
about mass shootings which we are i
think sane people around the country see
this happening and say okay what do we
do about it no parent wants to sit and
worry that their kid's going to go to
school
and
be in danger in that it's horrifying
it's distressing it's it can it can
induce panic anxiety all if you really
care about that
then advocate for things that will
actually fix the problem maybe when all
of these red flags arise on a person you
see every single time there's a mass
shooting
they get the gunman
they get the perpetrator and then you
all of this stuff unfolds about them 67
red flags the family knew x and y
behavior was going on friends at the
school knew this was going on there was
this incident that happened two years
before
there was this incident that had been
reported to police but nobody
over and over and over again you say why
at some point
when red flag number 65 hit why didn't
anyone do anything about it the system
needs to be reformed you wanna you wanna
really stop mass shooting stop worrying
about what song you're saying at a
concert that nobody equates with math
shootings and start advocating for the
system to be fixed you want to fix mass
shootings get rid of the gun-free zones
i told you they are criminal
magnet zones everybody knows that
everyone with common sense knows that
you want you want to fix the problem you
have to allow law-abiding citizens to be
armed you have to criminals need to know
that when they arrive somewhere with
their gun they are going to face a gun
an armed trained law-abiding person who
is going to attempt to stop them
so i'm tired i'm tired of these
celebrities that come out and this
nonsense it's like all of this virtue
signaling then they go on twitter it's
like oh what are they going to do to
prevent massive oh let's start a hashtag
let's start a hashtag that'll fix it so
they start some ridiculous hashtag and
then they're all it's like a way to like
pat yourself on the back like you're
doing something to help a situation and
you're doing nothing
and in the same breath often times
advocating for policies that make this
stuff worse in the same breath you'll
say oh i'm not going to sing hit me with
your best shot i wouldn't be surprised
if she's a big advocate for gun control
if she's a big advocate for the guns out
of every i would that would not surprise
me one [ __ ] it's very liberal so it
would not be surprising to me
in fact i don't know if you know this
benatar previously penned this is from
the blaze a feminist anthem
in order to protest the election of
former president donald trump these
people are so predictable
you're so predictable it's like
nauseating
just once think outside the box don't
tell the line with hollywood at large
because it's cool in your circle just
have a mind of your own is that so hard
you want to fix the problem talk to me
about how you're actually going to help
fix the problem be a voice for that not
for this can you imagine she thought
that people in the club sing and hit me
with your best shot
are somehow equating i mean that song to
machines and that if she didn't sing it
she was somehow proactive in the cause i
mean can you even make this [ __ ] up
anymore real quick i want to give a
shout out to kyle lopez big fan boy but
no all that's going through my head is
like a seth rogen comedy where some guy
is about to go shoot up a mall and he's
got his airpods in and all that's
playing is pat benatar's like it's it's
comedic like give me a break right
exactly what these people are like you
really
you have to at some point just laugh and
and disregard right you can if you're if
you're gonna be this ridiculous like you
just can't you can i mean you can still
have a seat at the table and say your
piece but come on man
i mean just
i don't even i'm without words at some
point which is you know there was a
thing there was a cnn op-ed i read this
morning that came out on real clear
politics and it said good guy with a gun
question mark the problem is all guns
and they were referring to the guy in
indiana the 22 year old indiana who
stopped the mass shooter and it said the
mass shooter went in
and he shot three people injured more
and terrified others but the good guy
wasn't really a good guy because the
mall didn't allow weapons and he ignored
the ruling but made no mention no
mention of the shooter that stormed in
with a rifle yeah i actually he'd listen
to the the no guns in the mall rule
right i think that somebody had put in
my timeline that i think my old friend
sunny hostin
we were friends before she decided she
didn't like that i didn't get the
vaccine
i don't know man but i think she had
made that argument on the view something
like well he broke the law he and
suddenly the focus came to the guy who
was trying to prevent the pro you know i
really i'm this is what i'm trying to
say people and austin you know one thing
that there's you know what i would love
to have somebody on here sometimes i
think out loud on the show guys you have
to forgive me for that but it comes to
me i make a note
on the topic of guns i mean the media
illiteracy is so profound i mean really
and i didn't i grew up in new york city
i didn't grow up in a house where like
the second amendment was like an active
presence in our house where you were
going out and shooting you grew up texas
probably was a lot different for you but
when you see media illiteracy it's
amazing the things they say assault
rifles they don't know what they're
talking about
i mean do a little research before you
take the mic just do a little research
i've never seen media personalities look
dumber than when they talk about guns
and like i said i didn't grow up with it
but i went i do my research i learned
what i can i ask experts i admit that
i'm not an expert that i may make a
mistake i inquire
you know have a curious mind don't
embarrass stuff they go on there talking
like they're experts they don't know
what end is up or down then you see them
i don't know if you saw that ad gavin
newsom holding the gun
dana lash commented she's an expert on
guns and she commented that was the most
awkward thing i had ever seen and i mean
it just looks like
like that like he never held a gun
before and he was like oh this will make
a great i think it was gavin newsom or
was it uh
it was gavin oh another one i think was
dr oz something came up with guns on him
at one point so just all i'm saying is
just you know media
media celebrities honestly just a little
bit of research just a little bit of
research wouldn't hurt there it is
they're like what is what's going on
there
what is going on there you don't know
what he's doing is that not the most
awkward i mean people who who train i
know i have a few fans on here that
train people and fire i mean look look
what you're seeing with a firearm there
and this stuff get is dangerous you know
i mean if your message is that these
guns are dangerous maybe you should
figure out how to pick one up before you
go on video bright spark
i really can if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]